[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de pas
faux nous allons aborder toute
l'actualité et l'actualité politique
d'actualité sociale l'actualité aussi de
l'université puisque vous savez qu'une
réforme qui est en cours et pour en
parler florence mercadé qui est avocate
au barreau de versailles
stéphane mans sont poissards
l'université de versailles saint quentin
donc je lui ai dit bonjour et enchanté
vincent couronne bon je vous ai enseigné
aussi à l'université versailles saint
quentin vous êtes le fondateur du
mouvement des surligneurs voilà qui
remet dans le droit chemin ce qu'ils
disent des bêtises et offrira d'ailleurs
de ce mouvement parce que vous lancez
une opération de courte founding quand
on dit d'appel a l'argent pour financer
ce jeudi recevant bordant cette
association qui fait du bien à la
citoyenneté et jean charles lajoie ni
éditeur bonjour en jeu alors il ya
beaucoup d'actualité ou va commencer et
par une actualité locale vous savez qui
nous change - changement de président à
50 ans animé puisque jean michel
fourgous et le nouveau président assène
le maire d'elancourt il remplace michel
logique a été élu au sénat
c'est la conséquence de la loi sur le
cumul des mandats on peut pas maintenant
cumulé demande à combien on peut pas
comme il le demandait si on peut résumer
les choses on me semble qu'on ne peut
pas cumuler un mandat d'exécutif local
avec un mandat national le mandat
parlementaire c'est-à-dire sénateur et
maire sénateur maire député maire
tout ça ça n'existe plus la ministre
c'est un mandat c'est une fonction
c'était fonctions mais les ministres
sont son sommet de démissionner par
exemple le ministre de l'intérieur qui
était maire de lyon n'est plus maire de
lyon politiquement mais juridiquement
non oui obligation éthique puisque le
drian était resté président du conseil
régional alors que tous les autres été
sommé de démissionner lui levé du banc
des messages
s'il est toujours mais à l'époque où il
était ministre et oui il est toujours
que non mais je veux dire au moment sous
soit le lendemain qu'il aurait dû
démissionner bas à ma connaissance on
donc ça mais ça c'est pas la loi la loi
ce sont les mandats et l'existant il est
prévu qu'elles qu'elles évoluent sur ce
terrain c'était une très longue
une très longue traîne en combat depuis
très longtemps des voix là il faudrait
que les que les élus se consacre un seul
mandat
il ya beaucoup de contestations là
dessus notamment je crois le président
du sénat gérard larcher il ya des
discussions entre le président de la
république est venu pour savoir si on va
pouvoir modifier la constitution avec un
non cumul des mandats dans le temps
là on est dans le dans l'espace ça
serait dans le temps et les sénateurs
notamment ils sont assez opposées et
puis il y avait cet argument quand même
pendant longtemps que si on n'avait
qu'une fonction nationale on pouvait
être coupé de la réalité de devra
contourner voulez qu'on fasse un duel
nature vous êtes plutôt contre
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats mais
le sera peut-être pas
disons la même demande excusez-moi
patrice que jean-charles soit plutôt ça
ne me ça me choque
jean charles ix est carrément la cgt
plutôt ses fans
je suis très opposé je suis très opposé
à cette a7 très très grande nocivité du
cumul des mandats alors on parle alors
moi je suis tout à fait pour le cumul
parce que je vois pas une seule raison
d'être contre en fait surtout c'est à
dire que l'an dernier
voilà un argument définitif non mais ce
que quand on est élu si on fait bien son
boulot
pourquoi interne et pourquoi s'interdire
d'avoir un homme politique ou un élu du
digne de ce nom qui fait bien son boulot
est ce que dans une société on vous met
dehors au bout de cinq ans dans un
ballon c'est terminé vous avez fait le
bout un boulot remarquable c'est terminé
le cumul non vous avez déjà fait deux
fois cinq ans ben non c'est terminé
ce serait ridicule aucune boîte ne fait
ça alors pourquoi est-ce que là aussi on
a un bon député un bon sénateur un bon
maire pourquoi est ce qu'on apprend par
une chute dans le temps oui et alors ça
c'est comme il l'entend et ensuite je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec le
président du sénat quand il dit on va
être totalement coupés du monde
on reproche suffisamment aux sénateurs
d'être dans leur cas et au député mettra
peut-être un peu dans leur monde de ne
pas du tout savoir ce que ce qu'est la
france fasse de ce qu'est le véritable
dans le tissu social le seul moyen
qu'ils avaient effectivement sénateur
maire député maire c'était très bien vas
y avait un ancrage local et on sait très
bien ce que c'est que les
responsabilités vraiment d'un maire
surtout d'une ville moyenne ne se prend
pas de de la mairie de paris où la
mairie de lomé du mail me d'une ville la
majorité des communes en france au gré
des petites communes ou des coupes des
communes moyennes que c'est très bien
d'avoir cette possibilité pour un député
ou pour amiens d'avoir dans leurs gardes
alors absolument indispensable et en
plus ils sont bons et que encore une
fois démocratiquement on les réalise il
ya aucun problème avec on cumule 2
jeux par exemple ce qui a beaucoup
d'enseignants qui cumule énormément de
choses énormément de postes qui voyagent
à droite à gauche qui vont donner des
des cours en faculté à tel ou tel
endroit non encore plus de cumul
le dernier journal il comprit jeu j'en
appelle à nanard non patrice je
m'insurge contre une attaque personnelle
enfin franchement j'en charge je n'en
reviens pas alors puisque vous attendiez
des arguments jean-charles en voici
quelques uns qui ne vous convaincront
pas aujourd'hui j'en suis assez persuadé
le cumul dans le temps laissons ça de
côté pour l'instant pour y revenir dans
quelques minutes mais le cumul de entre
plusieurs mandats le cumul entre
plusieurs mandats d'abord le premier
argument qui est un argument très très
très comme très politique qui consiste à
dire il faut un ancrage local aux élus
nationaux
mais les élus nationaux ne cesse jamais
d'avoir un ancrage local
regardez ce qui se passe sans pour
autant faire de l'antiparlementarisme
primaire la réalité à l'assemblée le
sénat n'en n'est pas loin c'est que nos
députés sont enfin était jusqu'à présent
là il ya peut-être un changement au
regard du renouvellement qui est qui
s'est opérée aux dernières élections
mais traditionnellement les députés
étaient présents à l'assemblée nationale
moins de deux jours et demi par semaine
le reste du temps nos députés sont comme
on dit sur le terrain le terrain entre
parenthèses je ne sais pas ce que ça il
va falloir qu'on m'explique ce que c'est
que le terrain ce terrain qui enseignent
des vérités qu'on ne trouve pas ré est
par ailleurs aussi j'aimerais savoir ce
qui se passe et j'aimerais
voila j'aimerais ce que savoir ce que
c'est que le terrain donc les députés
sont plus souvent dans leurs
circonscriptions qu'ils ne sont à
l'assemblée de surcroît les lois
actuelles qui datent de 2013-2014
n'interdisent pas un député par exemple
d'être conseiller municipal et au sein
d'un conseil municipal
je parle là aussi de ce que je connais
non pas d'un dogue mandat parlementaire
mais que vous avez une emprise assez
forte une prise assez forte pardon sur
la réalité
donc vous êtes pour une certaine
hypocrisie c'est à dire que tous les
députés qui était maire ont abandonné
leur mandat de maire il son premier
adjoint et du contenant la sacem ne
peuvent pas être premier adjoint charles
c'est une fonction exécutive
oui mais enfin ils peuvent être
conseillés municipaux conseillers
musique oui il est ce que dans l'ombre
gère la mairie on citera bien il
continue à gérer dans l'ombre que
monsieur collomb par exemple le suma ans
humala mairie de vie donc je je je
c'est probable c'est possible mais que
la loi enfin viennent poser que à une
personne un mandat une personne une
fonction moi je trouve ça très bien et
c'est extrêmement nocif de surcroît pour
une autre raison le cumul des mandats
c'est que le cumul des mandats à un
fâcheux effet de localiser des débats
qui devaient être de portée nationale
j'entends dire par là que la loi doit
s'appliquer sur tout le territoire la
loi est la même pour tous j'enfonce la
des portes ouvertes mais on s'aperçoit
que les parlementaires n'oublie jamais
et c'est normal puisque c'est là qu'ils
sont élus leur ancrage local
si bien que les débats de portée
nationale sont très souvent parasitée
par des intérêts locaux
j'ai un exemple précis en tête mais je
vous pourrez sans doute les multiplier
parce que je me suis penché pour le
statut vous me direz c'est un exemple
assez caricatural mais pour le statut
qui pendant un temps et est applicable à
la polynésie française et vous savez que
gaston flosse
j'allais dire paix à son âme je ne sais
pas s'il est en prison enfin où il en
sort mais il va irez-vous pour mieux y
rentrer après sans doute mais
le statut de la polynésie française a
été discuté au sénat et c'était édifiant
florence était sénateur la loi a été
faite sur mesure pour lui c'est ce qui
me caractérise c'est la mauvaise outre
le kkl des fachos ou bien sûr à wallis
et futuna tout à l'heure mais ce n'est
qu'un exemple
c'était un exemple absorbé l'an
caricatural le lait caricaturable faire
la loi
ça il faut que des phases 2d bien sûr il
faut se débarrasser les intérêts et on
arrive on n'est pas loin du conflit
d'intérêts donc alors se dit la députée
au lycée vers ils font la loi et ils
contrôlent le bal des mains de
représenter sur leurs élus
surtout pas souvenez vous de ce que le
présent chaban delmas avait avait
répondu à je ne sais plus quel député
célèbre qui se disait représentants des
électeurs de meurthe-et-moselle je crois
et chaban delmas avait dit non vous êtes
représentant de la france de fortes
voilà bien sûr on utilise dans une
circonscription mais on est élu de la
france les parlementaires sont élus dans
des circonscriptions mais pas par des
cévennes absolument voilà donc le cumul
des mandats c'est nocif
sans parler du cumul des fonctions qui
peut croire qu'un seul élu puisse gérer
une commune faire la loi et contrôler le
gouvernement à paris tout cela en même
temps joyeuse notre voie les deux
ministres en plus alors le tout avec le
recordman sais je sais c'est le canut et
qui a pendant année l'harmonie à son âme
ps1 pour le mais la loi a commencé à
être me dire en prenant l'exemple de la
canebière
roman mère du roi qui a été président du
conseil général de seine maritime qui a
été présent tout celle régionale de
normandie qui a été ministre et j'en
passe donc si la partie de 85 que les
choses ont commencé enfin évolué sur le
cumul vincent couronne moi je suis
plutôt dans la position de stéphane
c'est à dire que le fpi interdire le
cumul dans l'espace et dans le temps
c'est quand même une avancée je trouve
parce que on comme le comme le disait
très bien stéphane ans quand on est
député ou sénateur ont fait la loi et
quand on doit repartir en campagne pour
se faire réélire est ce qu'on se fait
réélire pour ce qu'on a fait dans sa
ville où est-ce qu'on se fait réélire
pour ce qu'on a fait au parlement est
sahili a effectivement là une confusion
qui fait que les lecteurs il sait pas
forcément pour pourquoi ils votent en
réalité mon maire et député en même
temps et il c'est un beau et bon moi
j'ai plutôt pour la séparation est pour
l'interdiction du cumul et cumule dans
le temps c'est un autre débat
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est que
en effet après les élections
sénatoriales
le président de la république n'a pas la
majorité pour faire une réforme
constitutionnelle donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai essayé d'avoir le soutien larcher
le président du sénat on peut peut-être
passé à l'université parce que d'abord
il ya des séries de faire beau dans
cette salle mais réforme de l'apb de
l'admission après post bac
le projet a été présenté ce matin par le
ministre par le premier ministre et par
la ministre des universités alors on
peut rappeler ce que en deux mots ce que
c'est
l'apb qui veut le faire l'apb alors
c'est en france ouais et son post bac
jusqu'à ce qui a été présenté ce matin
les lycéens donc vont faire des choix
avec des ordres de près avec des ordres
de priorité et font 24 choix en partant
du promener leur premier choix vrai
premier choix jusqu'au dernier d'après
ce que j'ai compris sur la réforme qui a
été présenté ce matin ni à trois points
alors un il n'y a plus il y aura plus
que dit chara et qui se complaît dans un
ordre de priorité y'a papa normes de
prêt du tout donc c'est pas je suis pas
a priori donc celle de m6 suit donc aura
pas de priorité sur ses dix choix dont
il ya moins de choix mais pas de
priorité et ensuite côté l'université
effectivement la veille avoir un
contrôle puisque les universités vont
avoir accès au dossier des ailes des
lycéens ce qu'il n'avait pas auparavant
donc ils ont ils avaient accès il avait
accéléré mais alors là c'est un des
critères mais il faut savoir est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir a demandé de
formation supplémentaires ça c'est le
deuxième prend le premier point c'est un
le il est admis ou pas admis lycéens le
2 il est admis sous condition d'avoir
une remise à niveau
mais alors ça j'ai pas du tour n'a pas
de détails sur ce point là ça va ça
s'est remise à niveau c'est sur quel
critère est ce que ce sont des critères
en fonction des facs fac fait ces
critères sont des critères nationaux ont
pas bah oui mais ça c'est frais ouais
mais alors ça bon alors c'est là il ya
un vrai débat là dessus je pense parce
que ça me parait niveau démocratique
assez le débat s'est quand même
dire qu'un type café un bac technique à
un peu le remettre au niveau pour faire
médecine confort en gros il faut pas
tourner autour du pot c'est un peu ça
quand même titre qu'il n'était pas de
bis donc non des castrais et qu'après le
niveau va compter enfin c'est peut-être
déjà le cas mais en tout cas c'est très
bien fait je sais pas si c'est le
minimum
la troisième chose si bas alors derrière
tout ça il ya un mot qu'on ne prononce
jamais qu'on ne peut pas prononcer en
université c'est le mot interdit
s'appelle le mot sélection c'est le mot
que j'ai bossé dur je relisais
d'ailleurs c'était c'était les déboires
de perrefitte et en 63 alors il raconte
que de gaulle disait déjà mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cette université où tous
les étudiants peuvent venir il s'assoit
s'ils peuvent s'asseoir même fait qu
schiste et et en 63 sec au schiste et 67
qui revient là dessus en disant voilà
faut il faut faire la sélection et
fouché qui était l'ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale auquel superfeed
avait succédé va voir peyrefitte et lui
dit surtout ne faites pas ce que de
gaulle dit pourtant ne pouvait pas
suspecter christian que je ne pas être
gaulliste pompidou et moi on connait
mieux l'université que fédéral et on
sait ce que ça va faire
est-ce que ça a fait ça est fait d'une
certaine façon mai 68 et le départ de de
gaulle et puis après on 86 il ya la loi
devaquet alors là on parle vraiment de
sélection et ça entraîné les
manifestations étudiantes conseil la
mort de malik oussékine est probablement
la défaite de
de chirac en 88 au aux élections
présidentielles petit rappel historique
comme ça mais mais mais c'est vrai que
depuis alors tout le monde a très peur
d'utiliser de mou c'est pour ça que là
on appelle ça les prérequis mais la
vraie force de l'apb monde ne sont pas
de votre sélection
au fond les questions que vous posez pas
parce qu'on est toujours y ait pas de
sélection à l'université mais est
totalement fou il existe par l'entrée
mais sélection n'en parle pas à
l'université mais du n'en parle pas
parce qu'on l'a fait oui parce que les
étudiants la vivent au quotidien
on n'en parle pas en dehors de
l'université mais la sélection mais il
n'y a que cela pourquoi est-ce qu'on
commence moi je fasse je parle avec les
étudiants elle ne dit pas qu'elle n'y a
pas de sélection pourquoi est-ce qu'en
première année vous êtes des cohortes de
j'ai pas chez nous faculté de droit ils
sont ils sont 700 et pourquoi est ce que
dans l'amphi un troisième année vous
êtes 250
ils sont où les autres évidemment il ya
une sélection et de surcroît une
sélection extrêmement rude extrêmement
sévère extrêmement hypocrite extrêmement
coûteuse coûteuse parce qu'il faut
parler de sous il faut parler d'argent
coûteuse pour la société bien sûr
séduction naturelle qui se fait aussi au
cours du premier trimestre bien les
élections par le découragement
bien sûr alors la question c'est est-ce
qu'il faut rester dans ce système là où
la sélection se fait ou cours des cours
d étude et puis après dans l'arrivée sur
le marché du travail ou est ce que il
est plus simple à faire avant de mon
point de vue il faut pas qu'on ne peut
pas continuer dans ce système ça fait
des années qu'on aurait dû qu'on aurait
dû changer de système
mais c'est un choix apparemment d'après
ce que je vois dans les sondages but 60
66 % des français seraient favorables à
une forme de sélection soyons prudents à
l'université ça ne touche pas le leur
enfant est dans les bonnes familles
c'est bien qu'on second se pressent à
aiguilles et ses propres enfants vers
des filières sélectives je suis
convaincu pour en avoir parlé avec des
collègues depuis des années que si on
faisait croire que l' université
sélective était sélective alors que à
l'entrée alors que en réalité ne le
serait pas les choses les choses
changeraient dès qu'on instaure à
l'université des filières sélectives à
l'entrée nous en avons de plus en plus
mais il ya une rue et les gens les gens
s'y précipitent donc qu'on ne dise pas
que les que les français voire même que
la plupart des étudiants sont contre je
le tout démontre le contraire donc ce
système est et est un système
épouvantable c'est un site c'est un
système qui de surcroît absolument
absolument pascal ce qu'était par
dessous tout épouvantable c'était le
tirage au sort a lieu ce soir en allant
au delà de la bêtise
ça m'est donnée cet absurde biosynex
effet retard donc tout beau tout vaut
mieux que ça qui explique peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui je dise à parer à tout
est revenu une sélection sur certaines
filières ou en tout cas une orientation
plus plus plus plus forte si on peut
dire oui au jour là j'ai des débouchés
là je pense qu'il faut les deux il est
une orientation ce qui suppose une très
bonne information ce que ce colis séjour
je pense que c'est très compliqué parce
que les conseillers d'orientation je
lisais le président du syndicat des des
proviseurs là qui disait il ya il ya en
moyenne un demi conseillers
d'orientation admirer le langage
administratif au passage pour deux mille
élèves en terminale enfin ou quelque
chose comme ça voilà pourquoi mais il
parlait de son de son établissement
de surcroît les conseillers
d'orientation sont pas forcément les
mieux informés sur ce qu'on fait à
l'université je me sa geôle et je le
regrette beaucoup mais je les observais
il faut il faut il faut informer
d'ailleurs les lycéens et leur dire en
effet moi j'ai eu dans apb accès à des
dossiers puisque nous traitons des lots
6 l'apb tous les un à un
un bachelier hôtellerie qui demandait
son intégration en première année de
droit
alors je n'ai plus maître queux avis
très défavorable
mais si ça se trouve cet étudiant que je
salue au passage et peut-être avec nous
en première année en premier en droit je
lui souhaite de réussir mais je n'étais
pas franchement
et puis il faut sélectionner aussi
florence il faut sélectionner
il ya des manières de sélectionner qui
alors mais qui suppose une
reconfiguration du système parce que
évidemment ceux qui sont pas privés il
faut leur donner aussi d'autres
possibilités
il ya des systèmes assez intelligent
comme je sais pas le système canadien
que je connais un peu où vous avez en
fonction du résultat de vos études
secondaires
vous avez plus ou moins accès à une
offre qui est plus ou moins large
ceux qui ont les meilleures notes ont
accès à tous et puis ensuite vous avez
des filières qui se ferme au canada et
aux etats unis c'est la médecine qui se
ferme en premier ensuite vous allez
droit qui se referme et c'est bon alors
on peut c'est un système parmi d'autres
[Musique]
oui psycho est plutôt oui mais voilà on
peut on peut réfléchir mais il est temps
il est temps de il est temps de changer
j'ai cru comprendre que dans la réforme
au deuxième trimestre conseils de classe
du 2è trimestre et devrait y avoir un
avis sur l'orientation est déjà l'un
doit être donné et vous faites bien de
parler de cela parce que cet avis je moi
je danse je vois dans les dossiers il
existe déjà c'est le conseil des classes
il ya avis favorable ou défavorable et
ensuite nous universitaires nous nous
consultons s'assure sur une application
qui est une espèce de des coulisses
d'apb où nous avons accès aux bulletins
au bulletin du lycéen depuis l'assaut de
la classe de seconde et on peut regarder
mais je voulais 10 pour ce bachelier
hôtellerie je ne peux donner cali c'est
compliqué puisque vous êtes en cdd pour
tous les deux un lycéen
quand ils arrivent en fin de droits mais
ils découvrent un monde qui ne
connaissait pas s'ils n'ont pas exagéré
c'est pas du tout ce que c'est le droit
ap un juge moi en tant qu'étudiant
honoraires je peux ouvrir voit la
première année on découvre des choses
qu'on n'a jamais appréhendée absolue sur
ce que c'est
absolument mais sauf que donc comment
compliqué j'entendais un syndicat un
syndicaliste lycéens qui disait vous
rendez compte le scandale maintenant
c'est les profs qui vont nous dire nous
conseiller sur ce qu'il faut contre jour
vous allez vous allez chez le maître
vous même
où va-t-on si les enseignants semaine
est maintenant à savoir ce qui a priori
peut-être pourrait être souhaitable non
pour un lycée et même la médecine c'est
la même chose
bien sûr mais c'est vrai que pour le
coup là
il faut qu on fasse votre rôle aussi
d'orientation il faut qu'au lycée il ya
une orientation la plus en amont qui
soit faite mais là contrairement à ce
que à ce que dit stéphane moi je pense
pas que la sélection soit forcément
l'alpha et l'oméga l'aider des problèmes
de l'université
d'autant plus que quand on a 18 ans
quand on sort du bac
je pense qu'on a vécu aussi enfin moi
peut-être plus récemment mais bon c'est
être un peu plus frais mais le natal je
ne voulais pas laisser jean charles en
tout cas on a collé tous les deux ça
c'est sûr de moi là une fois qu'on a
passé le bac
effectivement il ya ce choix qu'est ce
qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
comme études et c'est vrai que le droit
on sait pas ce que c'est l'économie la
psycho on n'a pas forcément fait un
lycée et donc il faut découvrir et puis
personnellement à 18 ans je sais pas ce
que je voulais faire de ma vie
et alors je suis parti en fac de droit
c'est au 18 ans je suis parti en fin de
droits un peu par défaut et puis film
ans au fur et à mesure le travail ça et
je vous le dis est ce que l'université a
pas vocation aussi alors ça va être
terriblement responsable du point de vue
des finances publiques ce que je vais
dire mais à accueillir justement tous et
tous ces étudiants tous ces bacheliers
qui ne savent pas vraiment où aller qui
ont besoin de temps pour mûrir mûrir le
projet s'est déjà rendu ces garderies
mais oui mais en même temps on est la
peur peut-être qu'on peut faire débattre
entre vous et
ses fans encore non mais parce que tous
font qu est-ce que c'est parce qu'on n'a
jamais les muses débat qu'est ce que
c'est le rôle de l'université
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui c'est vous
d'épargné d'aider des étudiants et les
parents je pense qu'ils poussent leurs
enfants aller vers les filières
sélectives
messieurs les filières sélectives
ressemble un peu à ce que ce qui se fait
dans les grandes écoles
ben je dans les faits c'est dans
l'effectif un jeu je fais un grand
ensemble finir sélectif en soit toutes
confondues et j'y inclus les écoles est
d'ailleurs parfois mais enfin qui l'ont
qui est d'ailleurs emmanuel macron dans
le discours qu'il a fait à saclay
demandent à polytechnique école de
collaborer avec l'université même s'il y
aura de poule
oui un peu différent mais mais brille
voilà il dit arrêtez de vous chamailler
il faut offrir bon mais est ce que
l'université si tu demandais que risque
aux foulées pour dire les choses est ce
que les grandes écoles sont pas faites
pour fournir des gens pour là pour le
travail pour le monde du travail
et est ce que l'université ne serait pas
là pour faire des gens qui sont un peu
plus intelligent peu plus de réflexion
un peu plus de voilà vous savez ce débat
ce débat il existe depuis il existe déjà
mais il existe depuis le moyen âge que
ça y est elle est là il a été reformaté
au 19e siècle
vous parlez d'un côté d'une université
qui formerait des têtes bien faites
ça c'est le modèle de l'onu de humboldt
de l'allemagne du 19e siècle contre
versus une université qui ferait qui
formerait des têtes bien pleines
mais aujourd'hui on peut plus on peut
plus alors voilà c'est peut-être super g
n'hésitez entre ces deux universités est
contrainte par la parlotte par l'ordre
social par la société c'est ce qu'on
attend d'elle à la fois de former à des
métiers et de former des têtes bien
faites aussi et celle avantage de mon
point de vue l'université par rapport au
système des écoles et voire parfois des
grandes écoles il ya de deux atouts
considérables dans le monde dont dispose
l'université et non on ne dispose pas
nos écoles dans notre système français
c'est d'une part l'adossement
l'enseignement à la recherche et vous
parlez de polytechnique tout à l'heure
j'ai eu un billet de jeu croit jean
francis pécresse
l'autre jour qui se méprenait totalement
acquis fait enfin il se trouve que ce
billet m'a fait bondir parce que tu
entends qu'il illustrait une
méconnaissance absolue de cette question
il disait en gros c'est très bien pour
polytechnique parce que polytechnique a
besoin de partir dans les hauteurs du
classement de shanghaï vivre son destin
et puis de laisser la pauvre université
de paris sud accueillir ses milliers
d'étudiants dans des conditions pénibles
et s'est créé se méprenait complètement
parce que paris sud et au 41e le
classement tout ça ça va enfin avoir les
yeux rivés pessus de paris sud et au 41e
rang et politecnico 425e ça veut dire
que polytechnique a besoin de deux
universités beaucoup plus que les
universités pourraient avoir besoin de
polytechnique pourquoi parce que la
recherche à polytechnique n'est pas
développé et aujourd'hui si on veut
briller dans le monde en matière
d'enseignement supérieur il faut avoir
un adossement à la recherche
il ya un second atout c'est la
pluridisciplinarité
l'interdisciplinarité
quand on se promène dans l'enseignement
supérieur dans le monde convoite les
universités les plus brillantes celle
qui se distinguent sont les universités
pluridisciplinaires
c'est à dire ou les sciences peuvent
dialoguer entre elles ou les collègues
peuvent se regrouper ou on peut faire
des montées des filières des
enseignements pluridisciplinaires ce que
ne n'ont pas fait jusqu'à présent les
écoles faute d'être immergé dans un
milieu ouvert à la pluridisciplinarité
sans compter parents que des écoles
comme polytechnique ne fournissent pas
plus
d'étudiants aujourd'hui que sous
napoléon mais vous savez combien il ya
d'étudiants polytechnique il y en a il y
en a aujourd'hui entre 180 et 200 avec
la mise en place d bachelor il envisage
oui et alors qu'il faudrait il faudrait
probablement 1000 ou 15 cents et 1 lyon
par promotion sans doute mais voyez
c'est puis c'est un faux débat aussi
c'est chevènement avait bien vu la
sphère en disant notre système
d'enseignement supérieur et fait telle
manière que les meilleurs étudiants ne
rencontreront jamais les meilleurs
professeurs pourquoi parce que les
meilleurs étudiants sont dans les
grandes écoles et que pardonnez moi je
et que les meilleurs professeurs ils
sont dans les universités au regard en
tout cas des critères d'exigences qu'on
demande pour devenir enseignant
universitaire voilà alors continuons
comme cela c'est un choix de la société
c'est un choix coûteux c'est un choix
désastreux pour l'université
l'université auquel on a coupé un bras
et une jambe on a coupé on a voulu à
couper un bras
en matière d'enseignement en créant les
grandes écoles et on lui a coupé la
jambe de la recherche en créant les
grands organismes de recherche le cnrs
l'inserm etc
et c'est un système qui est de ce point
de vue là unique au monde
on aime bien être les seuls au moins
mais on est les 202 forcément meilleur
les écoles sont toujours intégrés aux
universités partout dans le monde et
elle ne s'en porte pas plus mal sans
couronne pour conclure ce que vous
disiez au fond oui versité plus ouverte
peut-être même si je suis d'accord sur
l'interdisciplinarité et le fait que les
grandes universités qui celles qui s'en
sortent le mieux c'est effectivement
quand l'étudiant il
les études sont adossées à la recherche
et qu'on est interdisciplinaire ça c'est
une évidence et jeu tout à fait d'accord
avec ça simplement en fait dans la
sélection à l'entrée à l'université
le risque c'est de perdre fait d'aider
des pépites des étudiants qui pourrait
tout simplement se transformer mais qui
seraient orientés vers des filières
différentes peut-être plus technologique
ou autres parce que en premier en
première année de fac de droit par
exemple médecine il n'était pas prêt et
bon plus tard parce que c'est c'est
comment dire il peut y avoir une sorte
de phénomène de chrysalide qui fait que
l'étudiant c'est pas ma seule permettre
à des gens là c'est encore c'est encore
différent sire que là on est vraiment
rentré dans la vie active et on revient
ensuite à l'université
c'est pourquoi cette idée d'aller
éventuellement de mise à niveau est
intéressant de passer un an à prendre
d'apprendre les bases de skoda de ce
verdict c'est très très bien audition
qu'on nous dise comment on va faire oui
parce qu'il ya une question de moyens
derrière tout ça
tout n'est pas une question de moyens
patrice l'armée en mai mais un peu quand
même
quand vous quand vous savez que
l'université numéro un dans le
classement de shanghai dispose d'un
capital de l'université de harvard dans
le massachusetts dispose d'un capital de
2 33 milliards de dollars pour 20 mille
étudiants ce capital pour 20 pour mille
étudiants et ce capital est gérée
gentiment afin de manière très
performante en capital par un budget
donc le nom mais vous avez travail
gentiment ils rapportent 660 millions
d'euros de dollars par an et il est géré
par là
la harvard business company management
company qui comprend 3 124 salariés qui
font travailler le capital d'harvard de
jeu voilà l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin fonctionner
avec un budget d'un peu plus de 100
millions 200 millions d'euros par an au
combien d'étudiants pour 20000 est allée
elle est si vous ne prenez que le revenu
donc 1 500 points plus quoi le rien que
leur bonne série et ça c'est sans
compter les dons la gare deux frères de
hong kong
ancien étudiant d'harvard qui viennent
de donner je crois 5e 5 millions de
dollars boyer pour l'autonomie des
années bien et je suis pour la pour que
les choses soient claires de notre moi
j'en suis pour que les choses soient
claires si on dit autonomie alors il
faut aller jusqu'au bout
l'autonomie et ce serait donc la
privatisation
comment est donc tombée via des
fondations c'est un fan association ya
une fondation excuse mais on voit bien
la différence de mentalité entre les
étudiants des universités françaises ont
quitté leur fait qu'ils ont quitté la
fac alors que quand on est en angleterre
où quand on est aux états unis on est
très attaché à son université on reste
mon nouveau batteur on va déjà donateurs
et viendra peut-être enfin ça c'est ce
qu'il faut et sait distiller est ce
qu'on cultive enfin notamment lu vs q ce
succès comme steve et de manière très
très un temps au travers de la fondation
oui mais pour vous donner une d'un
dernier mot voilà 33 milliards de
dollars le budget annuel de
l'enseignement supérieur français en
2018 terre pour toutes les universités
les écoles le système public en tout cas
c'est 25 milliards d'euros pour 60
établissements plus de 60 établissements
voilà donc tout n'est pas une question
de moyens mais voyez quand même on n'est
pas du tout dans le même seulement après
ça ce n'est pas la question sélection
c'est la question vraiment démissionner
j'ai aux etats-unis au royaume-uni
l'état finance beaucoup plus mais il ya
une plus importante l'université qu'en
france et en plus on rentre à sélection
par l'argent
oui c'est le ticket d'entrée pour le
second vous parlez bien s'il avait un
système de bourse qu'elle vous avez des
deux universités publiques qui sont qui
sont aussi à un ticket d'entrée à
l'équivalent de 4,4 ou 5000 euros par an
je pense à l'universel californie à los
angeles à san diego et san francisco
vous payez à peu près 4000 euros de mai
vous pouvez aller voir un temple si vous
voulez être avocat d'affaires à les voir
des avocats d'affaires américain qui
vous finance les études d'études bien
sûr dans une sorte de système absurde à
pascal lafargue
du coup c'est pas démocrate totalement
démocratique il ya quand même des aides
il ya des bourses est pas si
caricaturale n'est pas dupe aussi
caricatural je me présente parfois
balances ton port où leur me tout en
maintenant ses mythes où il ya des
manifestations en france je suis là
stein d'abord qui était une sorte de de
révélateur c'est pas fou est-ce qu'on
aurait été surprise au fond que
cette parole se libère comme ça d'un
seul coup l'impression qu'il y avait une
sorte d'étouffoir division des silences
de chape de plomb oui sinon depuis
toujours enfin c'est pas quelque chose
qui est nouveau cette cette
problématique de d'harcèlement d'un
scellement sexuelle pouvant aller
jusqu'au viol c'est quelque chose de
très anciens mais où une culpabilité de
la femme qui faisait qu elle se taisait
qu'elle ne disait rien se sentant
éventuellement toujours toujours faire
là sauf que là il ya un
voilà ça c'est un vrai bouquet a sauté
et je trouve que c'est assez fantastique
je ne connais pas une femme qui n'a pas
été au moins une fois dans sa vie
confronté à ce type de comportement
mais qu'est ce que ça va bien ce type de
comportement parce que je me sens quand
on mélange absolument tout le la grèce
l'agression le viol le harcèlement c'est
quand même les mots insensés comme trois
choses radicalement différentes et
parfois la drague lourde voilà je suis
comme très étonné si si et si chaque
femme s'est fait soi disant ont violé ou
agressé face vit pas dans le même monde
quoi je suis très étonné de devoir ou
alors faut vraiment faire attention
parce que j'imagine quand même qu'une
femme s'est fait violer doit l'avoir un
peu mauvaise de voir une autre jeune
femme qui dit ouais bah moi je suis fait
harceler dans le métro c'est pareil non
c'est pas pareil c'est radicalement
baissé
on a des dés de toute façon des
poursuites pénales qui sont différentes
viols tentatives de viol et le
harcèlement sexuel on est sur des débats
différents mais il y à cette espèce de
pression et de harcèlement alors en
restant il ya différents niveaux et
parfaitement raison de le dire mais ne
serait-ce que d'avoir ce qu'on appelle
vraiment du harcèlement sexuel c'est à
dire avoir une pression avec de se faire
plaquer contre un mur
on veut forcer essayer d'avoir arraché
un baiser c'est quand même quelque chose
d'un peu violent d'autant plus quand ça
vient quelqu'un qui a un pouvoir vous
parce qu'alors que ce soit le
harcèlement des femmes se soient son
employeur où que ce soit dans mes
qu'artistique ou dans les métiers de
prod ou je ne sais pas voilà de
quelqu'un qui a un pouvoir sur la femme
qui n'est pas le voir qui n'est pas que
le pouvoir de l'homme sur la femme de
l'homme sur la femme et le pouvoir
here are chic entre guillemets
deux dames sur une femme et ça c'est
parfaitement condamnables et ce sont ces
espèces d'harcèlement
[Musique]
sexuelle que des femmes peuvent subir de
façon peut-être un peu régulières après
moi j'ai passé l'âge donc non mais j'ai
eu à subir pouvoir au moins j'ai eu bien
sûr des choses mais en tant qu'avocat en
tant qu'avocate ça vous ça vous gêne pas
que des femmes balance comme ça des noms
changement au cube oui normalement après
j'espère c'est emballant que les noms on
prend la responsabilité de badens r nous
et de se faire pourrir espionnant
poursuivre c'est ce qui devrait saisir
la justice
cette campagne balance son port je sais
quand même apollon mais ils font il faut
qu'il faut il faut que les femmes
déposent plainte quant à lui ya lieu le
déposer leurs problèmes rappelé le
sketch de coluche ou effectivement ça
montre aussi un peu une comment dire une
défaillance de notre système c'est à
dire quelle que soit la gravité de
l'infraction du crime qu'on parle du de
harcèlement d'agression ou de viol il ya
quand même pour les harcèlements un
problème dans l'entourage qui fait une
pression sociale il fait qu'on n'en
parle pas pour l'agression sexuelle qui
fait que vous allez dans un commissariat
et très souvent vous renvoie chez vous
en vous disant si on essayait encore
pris et c'est encore bilbao n'est donc
ça les témoignages venant il a bandé et
ça montre que bombe à toutes ces femmes
que ça soit la pression sociale ou même
les la puissance publique qui ne les
écoute pas ça montre qu'en fait on ne
laisse en l'air sans ne leur parle on ne
leur laisse pas d'autre choix que de
s'exprimer sur twitter et de hockey à un
mouvement de balancier où il
exc ça va revenir dans combien d excès
précipiter une espèce de nez au
puritanisme ces milices qui totalement
tragique mexique mais ça va être ça je
sais ce que c'est ce que disait est ce
qu'ils sont pas juste des mains qui sur
des porcs la défense elle sort des
victimes à je me suis tu je ne me sens
pas je n'ai pas envie d'être une femme
jeu que quand on voit mais tous tout
s'était attablé c'était va demander à un
divan tu face à certaines monnaies à
longueur de journée de tous ces hommes
qui pour être tout à fait dans l'air du
temps dans une espèce de pensée unique
sont tous là en train de se battre la
coulpe en train de vie
j'aimerais tellement être à la place
d'une femme je me sens plus femmes
qu'aux hommes etc
tout ça est totalement ridicule quand je
dis tous les hommes ne sont pas des
ports et j'ai exactement le même
discours
allez allez peu faim c'est absolument
scandaleux quand comme attitude
non mais franchement toutes les femmes
ne se sont pas fait violer et tous les
hommes n'ont pas envie de violer la
première concédant 6 3 je suis désolé
c'est heureusement fait violer mais
entre le avant le viol il peut y avoir
quand même des agressions qui vient sur
blessure mais qui ne sont pas qui ne
sont déjà pas déjà parler parler des
agressions dans le métro comme si
c'était rien à rien ne se dit pas du
tout j'ai dit pas du tout que sais rien
je dis que c'est pas pareil c'est quand
même une belle ne niez pas une sorte de
globalisation baquet mais les quêtes a
fait qu'ils peuvent atterrir est
absolument c'est absolument terrible de
globaliser comme ça en moi oui tout se
vaut alors se ce panneau mitu enfin je
balance ton port largué tout tous les
mecs sont des cochons ok bon ben il faut
qu'on la dise ans n'a rien dit voilà
[Musique]
qu'on a changé d'époque
comment on a quand même élu un président
de la république et que tu peux parler
assez viril bros femmes par exemple
non c'est vrai le président macron non
non non après un salon de son scooter
pendant cette raison que j'ai suivi
comme jadis politique à un moment et en
effet voilà bon il y avait des propos
sur les femmes qui aujourd'hui aurait pu
lui valoir le pauvre paix a zappé mais
c'est vrai qu'on a changé d'époque sinon
c'est heureux ils ont déploré que
certains les spectateurs impuissants
d'un monde en train de changer
c'est ce que font penser ce à quoi me
font penser les les élus fallait les
anciens élus ou les anciens députés où
les anciens ministres etc qui sont là se
gausser à dire les petites mains aux
fesses de temps en voyant un petit
propos graveleux etc
on en a vu on avait beaucoup dans les
assemblées mais bien sûr et qui est
celui qui s'était fait siffler voilà
l'exemple parfait est ce que c'est
vraiment si c'est ça balance ton peur et
me tous et ça c'est sifflé sifflet ne
une femme députée karine qui arrive en
europe c'est ça qui vous choque
est-ce qu'en franchement selon elle a
donc eu d'autre part ça se présente on
sait à l'assemblée la ccir conciliant et
qu'elle est différent c'est quand on
s'est moqué jack lang qui arrive avec sa
veste à col mao en 80 quand elle était
élue député parce que quand il arrive
avec sa veste pour la siffler aussi pour
sa condition pour le fait que les urnes
qu'on se moquait entre des fans qui est
en passe
aucun des députés je dire que après la
femme dont vous parlez sont
incompétentes c'est un autre débat on
pourrait en parler mais non ça n'a pas
de rapport c'est pour ça que je veux
même pas entrer là dessus mais je dis ok
que des députés un peu un peu lourd
lascif ça ne semble pas être
caractéristiques d'une agression
sexuelle
je suis désolé s'est donc séparé doute
donc balances ton port ça va du manque
de respect jusqu'au viol et j'avais le
mélange balance conclure je crois non
regardez le danger des crises un sourire
non non mais si j'en ch mais on est
aussi dans une société commerciale qui
assez provocatrice et par exemple quand
on voit toutes ces affiches que avec
avec les pubs avec ses fans sont venus
l'automobile
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que dès leur faune présente la femme
comme un objet parce que c'est un objet
pour vendre du parfum pour demande du
café pour vendre du chocolat pendant
d'une automobile bien carrossées voilà
interdisons les liens séparation des
voies en maillot de bain non mais c'est
pas ça mais c'est que là du coup on
présente la femme comme étant un objet
il fut un temps mais à partir du moment
où elle est présentée comme un objet
très sexuée on peut se dire aussi mais
tient après tout c'est un objet donc ça
fait partie aussi d'une démarche de
notre société commerciale où il faudra
peut-être se poser sa question à la fois
c'est donc concrètement mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'il faut qu'une femme serait
venu allongé sur un lit pour vendre du
christian dior d'onduleurs on souffre on
supprime les bombes atomiques des
publicités et
ce qu'il faut qu'elles soient nus
jean-charles expliqué moir sont pas
vraiment du goût non non ça j'en parlais
d'une époque c'est notre avis ils
connaissent les villes
pourquoi pourquoi faut-il une femme en
slip pour vendre un véhicule terrestre à
moteur dites le moi lui les pires
meilleur sud fait la vaisselle me
montrer une publicité pour une voiture
et qu'une femme en slip qu'est moins de
20 euros
non mais là les i allez-y la prochaine
fois on se dit à l'écouté et la
publicité
ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pierre non
gagne plus on dirait juste pour dire
qu'il faut quand même arrêter ça
peut-être qu'on a reviendra quelque
chose de plus raisonnable la femme sera
moins présenté comme un objet il ya des
pubs qui sont qu'elle donne raison il ya
deux trois ans pour une voiture
allemande qui disait je parle de l'homme
ou plus pour une voiture allemande qui
est des quatre pieds pas vieille qe2
trois ans qu'ils aient approché qui
montrait un homme qui est dit est dit là
il a la force
il a la puissance il aura la femme que
ça c'est le jeu c'est la légèreté et le
monde y met alors je ne sais pas si on a
le tour de l'aborder là mais parce qu'il
y avait aussi et alors c'est vrai que
nos états unis
vous savez un d'enseignants par exemple
peut pas fermer la porte quand il
interroge une étudiante à yayi si oui en
france au sabbat avec les ide on écoles
en école primaire dans le soutien
scolaire on peut pas faire de soutirer
colère mais il n'y a pas deux personnes
payées une méfiance
ils ne furent plus accrue dans le
rapport homme femme aux états unis et il
y avait une philosophe qui expliquait sa
de manière assez intelligente en disant
qu'au fond le la société américaine est
fondée sur le contrat et pour passer un
contrat il faut que les deux volontés
soit égal
or la séduction ani l'une des neuf
planté et est-ce qu'on n'est pas en
train d'arriver à une société un peu
contractuels nous aussi plus que plus
que légaliste
voilà c'est une question que je vous
soumets et puis notre philosophe
allemand favori a interdit voilà que
dit-il de l'inini pas grand chose est
sûre en revanche en revanche son conseil
de papier d'abord masse dans le lobe ce
sur l' europe 1
vous l'avez lu je sais pour associer de
magnifique magnifique papier notre ami
jörg oehlmann très bon philosophe rénale
moi aussi puisqu'on parle de l'europe on
va parler peut-être des surligneurs
ces mouvements vous avez créé vous avez
dansé en cause du mouvement c'est une
association d'universitaires qui regarde
un peu ce qui se passe ce que 10 des
hommes politiques et qui leur prête
quand ils disent des bêtises et là on
peut parler de 12,3 faits récents par
exemple qui avait une députée qui
voulait mettre un drapeau blanc oui l
assemblée nationale
c'est donc dans tout le débat qui avait
mélenchon qui voulaient y ait pris les
drapeaux de l'union européenne à
l'assemblée nationale ils ont prétexté
des religieux la sous-préfète alors que
pas du tout aucun rapport iam tient un
petit rapport mais mais qui est pas
pertinente pour le rapport européen
mais du coup il ya une députée
effectivement marie-france l'euro qui
avait saisi l'occasion pour elle même
députée la ligue du sud oui exactement
et pour faux bronzes et deux placées à
l'assemblée nationale le drapeau blanc
voilà alors de la monarchie et donc elle
a proposé la déposer un amendement une
proposition d'amendement pour ce faire
mon amendement qui n'est pas passé n'est
nous ce qu'on avait dit c'est que en
fait placé le drapeau blanc l'assemblée
nationale ça heurte la constitution déjà
et nos principes républicains et pour
plusieurs raisons c'est-à-dire déjà
l'article 1er de la notre constitution
nous dit qu'on est une république laïque
le drapeau blanc c'est un drapeau la
monarchie et de droit divin donc c'est
nier ni républicain ni laïque et en plus
de ça il ya un principe constitutionnel
qui veut que dans notre pays les
édifices publics ne puissent pas
manifesté de préférence politique ou
religieuse et c'est aussi la loi par
exemple de 1905 sur la séparation de
l'église et de l'état est très
clairement le drapeau blanc c'est le
drapeau de la monarchie de droit divin
et donc forcément ça n'est pas
compatible avec notre chagrin plus
exactement comme ça c'est bordeaux
deuxième exemple donc vous avez traité
récemment mais c'est intéressant parce
que ça montre que ça va dans tous les
sens ça ne vous aide pas forcément
contre un quand la c1 contre un peu
contre nous le mettrons en tout cas nous
promet ce qu elle pas été tout à fait
tenu ses d'interdiction du d'être des
conseils pour les pour les députés tout
à fait alors ça c'était une fois que
emmanuel macron était élu président de
la république et qu'il a nommé son
gouvernement
il a tout de suite lancé le chantier la
moralisation de la vie politique et il
avait dit c'était dans son programme
présidentiel qu'il voulait interdire
toute activité de conseil aux
parlementaires nous on avait écrit à
l'époque que ça ne serait pas possible
on peut pas interdire complètement une
activité de conseil aux parlementaires
parce que le conseil constitutionnel
protège la liberté d'entreprendre et que
d'ailleurs en 2013 sur une proposition
de manuel valls à peu près identique il
avait déjà dit non et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé au final est bien la loi sur
la moralisation de la vie politique a
été adoptée et il n'a pas pu tenir sa
promesse tout simplement parce que ça
n'était pas conforme à la constitution
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé au final on
a une loi qui interdit à un
parlementaire d'avoir une activité de
conseil
si jamais cette activité a commencé
moins d'un an avant 16 heures voilà donc
donc ses promesses et ça on avait dit
alors on va parler de laurent wauquiez
dans un instant parce qu'il ya quelque
chose sur les travailleurs détachés sur
lesquels il a fait chaud juste un moule
la volonté d'opérations de crowdfunding
communiste la nouvelle seconde partie
cidre et simon partie festive
voilà qui marche plutôt bien parce qu'on
peut on n'est pas obligé de donner des
sommes en france est retourné en euros
dix mille euros si si on veut un sens et
c'est très relatif à ces accords ou
disons c'est bien fait ça vous aide
évidemment vous avez besoin de
financement pour pour faire les
recherches pour regarder ce qui se dit
et pour étudier évidemment exactement
alors il ya un site y incite les
surligneurs point eu et ça c'est notre
site internet sur lequel on peut
ou accéder à notre campagne de
financement participatif et en allant
sur ce site déjà ceux qui le
découvriront un peu verrons ce que c est
ce qu on fait et en quoi en fait c'est
vraiment un engagement pour l'état de
droit pour la démocratie et pour
vérifier en permanence que ce que disent
nous nos chers politiques
et lorsque c'est pas conforme au droit
alors c'est un site qui a très bien
marché pendant la campagne on a oui
débuté en janvier cela il ya une
collection aussi de propres ont été
soulevées sur 118 me suit depuis le
départ d'ailleurs un maintien depuis
début et ça c'est ça c'était c'est un
grand plaisir pour nous et ça a très
bien marché pendant la campagne
l'un maintenant peut poursuivre
l'aventuré mais pour continuer on a
besoin de moyens parce que il ya du
monde qui travaillent sur ce site on
travaille tous bénévolement
il faut payer les modifications du site
il faut payer les recherches etc
il ya tout un tas de choses qui nous
faut pouvoir financer et puis on a des
grands projets aussi je vais pas du tout
dévoiler ici mais on a des projets assez
ambitieux de développement et ça
pour ça évidemment sa demande comme pour
les universités des moyens d'argent ce
que je dis ça vous avez malgré une
député de droite emmanuel macron oui oui
ce que je peux dire sur les dons c'est
que justement grâce au foot au soutien
de la fondation du vécu tous les dons
sont défiscalisées ce qui signifie que
vous pouvez donner trois fois plus en
fait que ce que vous voulez donner au
départ si vous vouliez donner un euro
pouvait donner 3 euros mais devra
rembourser sur votre impôt sur le revenu
et si vous payez le sfc même les trois
quarts sur laurent vous l'avez pingre et
sur une déclaration sur le travail la
réforme de travailleurs détachés
oui exactement alors convoqué ce qui est
curieux c'est que là il s'est exprimé
sur les travailleurs détachés la
directive qui vient révisé renforcer le
ce régime là et ce qui est curieux c'est
que laurent wauquiez a quand même été
ministre chargé devriez donc il est
censé connaître un peu le fonctionnement
des directives et comment fonctionne
l'union européenne a priori pas vraiment
ou alors c'est de mauvaise foi parce
qu'il confond en fait l'entrée en
vigueur de la directive et le délai de
transposition c'est un peu complexe et
pour faire clair la directive sur les
travailleurs détachés la nouvelle avec
le nouveau régime devrait être mise en
place d'ici un an
hélas la france pourra l'adopter et si
elle le veut mais c'est vrai qu'elle
rashka 2022 pour le faire la fête et
laurent wauquiez avait dit on
as tu on instaure un nouveau régime on
renforce système travailleurs détachés
en prévoyant des les transpositions de
2022 ça ne sera pas fait avant 2022
oui alors ça dépend de nous à partir
nous on fait comment ces délais mais
voilà c'était une adresse alors ok voilà
vous avez vu c'est ce qu'il dit des
manuels macro
et il dit une chose qui est assez
intéressante a dit eddy le droit de
bingo c'est très bien mais au fond ce
sont les hauts fonctionnaires qui
gouverne dans ce cas-là inexactes au
delà du propos est ce qu'elle sera juste
une minute en ce qu est surtout
intéressant c'est que quelqu'un se
décide à s'opposer à maquereau moi
j'aime beaucoup le président macron mais
je trouve ça indispensable au moins un
opposant à nous posons de mélenchon ça
ne pesant digne de ce nom mais pas la
fin de mélenchon ce n'est pas crédible
en face à deux pas de sens mais le
positionne va être que de droite il faut
il faut une opposition intelligente
enfin qu'il faut pas quelqu'un qui
veuille plus faire descendre tout le
monde dans la rue enfin démocrate gdr
ccsa intérêts donc j'ai eu une
opposition de droite qui se revendiquent
de droite pourquoi pas et il y aura
peut-être un jour quelqu'un qui va
ressurgir à la tête du ps et qui
pourraient aussi s'opposer de l'autre
côté c'est tout ce que je souhaite donc
j'arrête
mais quand il dit tandis qu'emmanuel ma
vision comptable
en tout cas je peux peut-être mais ça me
paraissait indispensable parce que
depuis le dd des lustres on a des hommes
politiques qui dépense sans compter et
qui vécut donc voilà là se trouve ça
très bien que pour une fois il ya un
président qui compte un peu et
maintenant on arrête on arrête de jouer
la récré est finie même si parfait eh
ben c'est sur ces beaux qu'on va donc je
dis tout toute mon amitié tout mon amour
agen
ah non non non non qui a été ministre
des universités mais supérieure normal
normal c'est le secondaire l'esprit de
casse merci beaucoup florence père cadet
stéphane moreau roi sans couronne et
jean charles lajoie ni et à très vite
pour un nouveau numéro de baffes
[Musique]